Oh, Ben Affleck, how we love you for what
you've given to the Batman role.
Now, it's time for you to leave.
Sure, Affleck is the biggest star in the DC
Extended Universe of films.
But is he actually hurting both the franchise
and his own career?
Here's a look at some of the real reasons
Ben Affleck needs to get out of his Batman
contract.
Critical bombs
Let's face it: Batman versus Superman and
Justice League's critical receptions probably
aren't helping Ben Affleck's overall artistic
morale, what with him waking up every morning
to green splatters on Rotten Tomatoes.
Even Suicide Squad, in which he only made
a cameo appearance, tanked harshly with critics.
Considering Affleck spent years trying to
rebuild his reputation as a serious actor
after Daredevil flopped, he's just not doing
himself any favors by going down with the
DCEU ship.
An uncomfortable fit
Affleck's version of Batman is possibly the
grimmest one yet.
But is that a reflection of the overall dourness
of the DCEU?
Or is it a reflection of how Affleck feels
about playing the role?
Either way, fans and critics alike agree that
his work is suffering.
For instance, The Guardian's review of Justice
League said
"Ben Affleck is unrelaxed and ill-at-ease
in the role of Batman/Bruce, unconvincing
in both the bat armour and the three-piece
suit of the wealthy plutocrat.
[…] Affleck spreads a pall of dullness over
the film."
Polygon agreed, writing,
"Affleck's performance is barely passable."
Whether the cause is personal or professional,
it's clear to everyone that Affleck's heart
just isn't in it.
And exhibit A is...
The Sad Affleck meme
When Sad Keanu became a meme, Keanu Reeves
got a kick out of making fun of himself.
But even Sad Keanu feels bad for what happened
to Ben Affleck after his Batman versus Superman
interview with co-star Henry Cavill went infamously
off the rails.
"It taught me not to do interviews Henry Cavill
where I don't say anything and they can lay
Simon and Garfunkel tracks over it, that's
one thing I learned."
If there's one thing we know, it's that the
internet never forgets a good meme, and now
there's a whole generation, who knows Affleck
mainly as "that sad meme guy."
For the sake of his mental health if nothing
else, maybe he should get out before any more
memes come along.
Creative differences
When Affleck first signed on to play Batman,
it was a really big deal, and the Oscar winner
was set to direct, write, and star in a Batman
solo film.
It seemed as if he had been given total control,
and he was stoked.
"I wanted to be in one of these movies that
was ballsy and that had something to say,
you know?
And I wanted to do a movie that my kids would
think was cool."
But slowly, it became apparent that Affleck
and Warner Brothers were experiencing those
dreaded "creative differences."
First Affleck dropped out as director, then
he dropped out as writer.
And with new director Matt Reeves reportedly
pushing the film in a new direction, rumors
began that Affleck would drop out as the star
too!
Given the repeated votes of no confidence
shown him by the studio, why would Affleck
even want to stay as a puppet in someone else's
show?
A dignified exit
Speaking of director Matt Reeves, reports
have surfaced claiming that he wants to replace
Affleck as the man in the bat suit.
And there are plenty of stars who seem far
more eager than Affleck to don the cowl.
For example, Reeves apparently has his eye
on Jake Gyllenhaal, while Jon Hamm is also
reportedly gunning hard for the role.
"Lucky lad!"
"Feelin' lucky?"
Given how disappointing all the DCEU films
have been so far, we're not sure Hamm or Gyllenhaal
could do any better than Affleck has done.
But considering he no longer seems to be wanted,
Affleck could spare himself a lot of embarrassment
if he quit before Warner Brothers has the
chance to fire him.
The grass is greener
Considering Affleck has a proven track record
as a creative force, winning the Best Picture
Oscar for Argo in 2013 and the Best Original
Screenplay Oscar for Good Will Hunting in
1998, there are plenty of opportunities for
Affleck in Hollywood that don't involve being
a punching bag for fans, critics, his own
studio, and Superman.
Heck, before filming Batman versus Superman,
Affleck was on a roll, coming off of an acclaimed
performance in the 2014 hit Gone Girl.
That's the star that fans were hoping to see
in the DCEU.
And it's the star fans are now hoping they
can see pretty much anywhere else, because
since stepping into the role of Batman, Affleck
has been in a deep creative funk.
Given that Affleck certainly doesn't need
the money, and given that even his closest
family and friends are lobbying for him to
leave, here's hoping that he gets out of his
Batman contract sooner rather than later.
It wouldn't just make fans happy - it would
make both Warner Brothers and Affleck much
happier too.
And that's the kind of win rate even Batman
would be envious of.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!